you
[Music]
we have we are very lucky to have a
bunch of very very distinguished
speakers but in order to focus on the
science I'm going to keep the
introduction to a minimum in the main
sessions they are all very distinguished
nonetheless
so Daniel Hsu from Columbia University
is going to tell us about predictive
models from interpolation okay thanks
Sebastian thanks for the invitation this
is a great workshop and when the talk
tell you about predicted models from
interpolation and so a lot of the
introduction to my talk it's already
been covered by Peter but I'll just run
through it a little bit so maybe this is
not a surprise anymore but maybe a few
years ago maybe we might have thought
that you know when you look open up a
textbook that you know overfitting to
the training data might might be
considered something that would lead to
bad predictive performance out-of-sample
and this was certainly the case for you
know that the people have been buying
into this conventional wisdom and it's
really been sort of deep learning
empiricists who have really raised this
question again in the past of several
years
whether this is actually the right
intuition to have and we're going to
give some empirical and theoretical
evidence the account goes against this
conventional wisdom at least for the
types of scenarios that are coming up in
practice these days okay okay so here's
an outline of the talk I will describe
some of these empirical observations
that that Peter already kind of touched
upon and this will motivate us to look
at some certain kinds of interpolating
rules for supervised learning one based
on local prediction because these are
ones that we understand well and of
course we would like to eventually to
understand interpreting rules based on
neural networks okay just so we're all
on the same page we're talking about
supervised learning so supervised
learning is when you have training
examples typically we assume that there
is on and these get passed through a
learning algorithm that produces some
prediction roll a prediction function on
which we want to classify or make a
prediction about a new test point and we
measure whether our prediction is
accurate based on some loss function and
we care about what happens in
the average case sense so what has
happened in the past several years with
people studying deep nets but also other
kinds of sort of large predictive models
that they are finding that these sort of
large models can interpolate any
training data that's perhaps not
surprising at all but that was sort of
interesting it that they also generalize
well that in other words they have good
out of sample prediction performance
even when you're trying a fitting
perfectly fitting noisy training data so
here's a plot from a paper by a Belkin
MA and Mandel where they show they add
noise to some supervising training data
and you add just by randomly flipping
some of the labels and you would expect
that if you look at the test error at
the end the day that it does increase
it's the mountain noise that you add but
doesn't immediately shoot shoot from you
know zero to two the the trivial noise
rate which is 90% in this case which is
that this is a 10 class problem I think
it's M this but instead it kind of stays
not too far from what the Bayes optimal
classifier rate is for de faria kinds of
models so this is two different kernel
machines and as well as a two layer
fully connected zero neural network so
they you know the tester is maybe what
you would expect from the base risk plus
some some small amount okay so maybe
this is not totally surprising because
we've have seen large predictive models
of work well I'm sample but this is
maybe surprising in the context at least
for regression where we are literally
fitting the noise and the training data
and and yet we have good predictive
performance so at least in the context
of classification people kind of had a
good understanding of what was going on
and certainly people studying
nonparametric methods and statistics
knew that you know it's not it's not
necessarily a bad thing to have very
large large models there are many many
parameters and indeed some statistician
for
at the some some different class of very
large I predicted models these are
boosted decision trees where they were
able to interpret these things at least
empirically as some kind of local
interpolation methods and they argued
that the the locality of these these uh
prediction roles the flexibility these
prediction roles is what gives the these
these models their the predictive power
in other words that they are very robust
to label noise so here they're trying to
illustrate this phenomenon where if you
have a less flexible prediction role
like a linear classifier and there's
some label noise you would have to
drastically fit sort of change the
prediction rule to deal with a
particular label being being noisy Rad's
a more flexible prediction role with
would be able to accommodate that a
noisy label much more gracefully so this
gives us some inspiration to look at
local prediction rules for why it is the
case that we can actually do
interpolation and still effective it out
of sample prediction performance so
before our work we we knew up to local
interpolation methods that had been sort
of studied and analyzed in the
literature one is super well known which
is nearest neighbor so everyone knows
this if you take machine learning 101
you know that this is a classifier or a
prediction rule that perfectly
interpolates the training data assuming
you know the node you don't have
replicate any data points with
conflicting labels and we you know and
sometimes really understand it's a its
properties it's a prediction error sort
of converges asymptotically to something
like twice the Bayes optimal risk and
another method that's also slightly less
well known but it surprisingly has very
surprised surprisingly strong
theoretical guarantee is this a
smoothing kernel method called the
Hilbert kernel I think outside of
statistics is called the Sheppard's
method this also turns out to
interpolate training data and it has
some kind of consistency property as
long as your data
a density you can show some kind of
consistency that's n goes to infinity
the the risk approaches the Bayes
optimal so there's some things that are
not like not nice about it for instance
there aren't convergence rates and
there's other other deficiencies about
this rule but this least gives us some
hope that this you know this is the
plausible explanation for why it is that
we can construct prediction rules that
interpolate training data and yet are
get good at a sample performance so the
goals of our the goals of this online at
work is to first try to counter this
conventional wisdom that you know
perfectly fitting training data
necessarily leads to bad predictive
performance so we can show that there
are some contrition methods that are
consistent or in the sense that I'll
describe later almost consistent for
both classification and regression and
I'll describe two of them they're based
on local local interpolation and then
I'll try to say something about neural
nets but given some caveats they're
really about linear models but
throughout this we'd like to try to
identify what are the useful properties
of these methods that make the
interpolation benign or give good
out-of-sample performance okay and of
course we would ultimately like to make
connections to practical methods okay so
this will be the so I'll kind of go
through these three three methods
depending on how much time I have so
let's start with the two local
prediction rules okay so the name of the
game here is to try to estimate the
regression function so the regression
function is the function that has the
smallest mean squared error
out-of-sample it's just the conditional
expectation the label will give in the
input X and these local prediction rules
try to construct some estimate of this
function and if you were to use this for
binary classification let's say the
labels are just 0 or 1 and this is just
the conditional probability that the
label is 1 given the input and the
optimal classifier is just by threshold
and a half and you can construct the
classifier just by threshold in your
estimate 8 a hat at 1/2
and so what do we mean by good predictor
for warrants we we care about what
happens with the out-of-sample
prediction because I'm in sample
everything is a your training err or
training loss it's all it's only zero
because you're interpolating the
training data so we care about what
happens at a sample well we also care
about what happens out-of-sample you
know let's say as you collect more and
more data as n goes to infinity and how
quickly it approaches whatever it
converges to so let me describe the
first method that we constructed for for
this which is simple issue interpolation
Peter mentioned this in his talk so in
this method the basic idea is to
construct some kind of multivariate
triangulation of your training data I've
just based on the X parts so let's say
that your X's come from okay I didn't
say here but let's okay so so X's are
our D dimensional vectors and the Y's
are labels between 0 and 1 for
classification it would be 0 or 1 and so
the way this interpolation works is that
you can track some triangulation of your
training examples x1 through xn of the
convex hull of your training examples
for instance using Delonte triangulation
this is just the if you just look at the
Voronoi diagram that you associated with
nearest neighbor this is the dual of
that something and in our prediction
roll will be two on a new point X its
first locate which triangle or simplex
and D dimensions contains that point X
and then to do a linear interpolation of
the vertices of that simplex so the
vertices of the simplex will be actual
training examples
there'll be d plus one of them if you do
a linear or affine interpolation of
their corresponding labels your
prediction rule will go through the will
perfectly fit the labels of the training
examples but for any other point inside
the simplex it'll be some linear
combination of the labels of the
training labels so the resulting
function that you construct is some
piecewise linear function on the convex
hull of your training example
it kind of looks like this at the black
points here are your training examples
the I think the the purple lines here
show the Voronoi diagram and the black
lines show you the the faces of the of
the of the simplest C's in this
triangulation so all the action
basically happens on one of the you know
when you locate which simplex your
prediction point your test point lands
in or I should say okay so when you want
to do as I said before if you're doing
classification you just threshold your
regression estimate at 1/2 so so all the
action to analyze this method happen you
just need to consider what happened on a
single simplex so let's look at one
simplex let's say with vertices X 1
through X D and let's say that the
corresponding labels and your training
data or y1 through Y D or B plus one and
let's say that your test point is right
here so you need to make a prediction
there what we'll do is just do a linear
or affine interpolation of the labels of
X 1 through X D plus 1 and so this point
here the way that happens it at this
point here has some sort of barycentric
coordinates in terms of in this simplex
so X can be written as some comic
combination of X 1 X 2 up to X D plus 1
and an our linear interpolation will be
exactly the same weights and to use to
combine the labels at X 1 3 X D plus 1
so that will be our estimate or
prediction for the label at X here okay
and so you kind of see what is happening
here which is that when you're making
this prediction you are aggregating
information from the labels of D plus 1
data points and this is in contrast to
say the one nearest neighbor rule which
is just take the label of just this the
closest a training example it just
doesn't aggregate any information so
already we see a difference with the
nearest neighbor role and we can make
this kind of illustrate this much more
[Music]
dramatically in a very simple case so
here's a particular set up so let's
suppose that in
put in the simplex I've drawn here the
true labels sorry the the regression
function for all the points in that
simplex the regression function is less
than 1/2 it so the probability of a
label 1 is less than 1/2 so the right
thing to do there is to always predict 0
you could that would be this give you
the smallest class and probability of
classification error but suppose you
know on your training data you had noise
so this is so you're going to fit this
noise and most of the points that don't
have noise and one of them does
okay so noise here means that the label
is 1 even though the probability of a
label being 1 is less than 1/2 now we
can look at in this particular simplex
what happens with the prediction rule
that you construct based on nearest
neighbor and based on simple
interpolation so based on nearest
neighbor what do you how do you make a
prediction you look at the point and you
look at what's the closest point to to
it maybe it's x1 x2 or x3 well this is
the region in which x3 the nearest
neighbor and you would go with the
prediction of the you would predict with
the label of x3 in this case which would
be a1 and that's you know goes against
what the the Bayes optimal classifier
would predict where as in simplicial
interpolation you do a linear
interpolation you take into account the
labels of x1 and x2 you know and so on
as well and this sort of reduces the
region in which you are actually going
to make a classification mistake and you
can kind of visually see that there's a
difference in the size of the regions
here and this is something that will get
magnified in high dimensions so this is
the intuition for why you just you know
these kinds of averaging rules in high
dimensions can give you some improvement
over what happens with you know more
simplistic rule yeah so ok so the way so
Ilya is asking a good question is there
something that you can actually
implement turns out yes so just like you
know Voronoi diagram is it's from some
kind of large object
so is the case with the the
triangulation but we don't actually need
to construct the triangulation
explicitly so a nearest neighbor you
don't actually have the constructive or
in our diagram usually the algorithm to
make the prediction the same thing can
happen with simpler interpolation you
just need to locate the the simplex that
contains your test point and this can be
done by solving a linear program so the
main thing that needs to happen is that
these triangle the triangles or
simplicity's cannot be too elongated and
so doing a Deewani triangulation ensures
something about that yeah there
certainly would be some triangulation
that are not we're not have a nice
property here but in higher dimensions
even de Launay will produce a lot more
skinny triangles I mean fundamentally
issue with inflation so we can at least
control you can can always control sort
of the aspect ratio in any dimension
just based on the idea that it's the
deal of the Voronoi diagram so so at
least the theorem this theorem will be
for de l'année triangulation the any
triangulation that has can control this
aspect ratio so this theorem it's about
the asymptotic risk of this particular
prediction role so let's just look at it
for classification because that's the
kind of scenario they described before
so there's some pretty strong
assumptions on the data distribution but
it sort of illustrates the point that I
want to make here so the data
distribution should be uniform with some
convex set and the regression function
should be always bounded away from 1/2
it's just like an easy classification
problem where something sort of
effectively some kind of margin so what
happened so we know exactly what would
happen for nearest neighbor it was still
converge to something kind of like twice
the base risk but in this case with
simple xu interpolation the the risk the
expected 0 1 loss converges to something
that's bounded by you know something
closer to 1 ok was it close to 1 times
the base risk what was
one plus something that's exponentially
small and in dimension and this is sort
of a to be expected because you are now
being aggregating information from not
just one you're not your prediction not
just based on one data point but on D
plus 1 data points right so the
comparison point here is nearest
neighbor
ethem pathetically it converges to
something kind of like twice the base
risk okay when you say something I'm
also about regression for regression
error is sort of like one plus something
get smaller and hired and higher
dimensions okay so we already see some
benefit of high dimensions and averaging
and the same thing can be done with a
different interpretation scheme which is
based on sort of an analogue okay
nearest neighbor so regular K nearest
neighbor if not interpolating because
you are doing some averaging or voting
over your K nearest neighbors but if you
do some weight it's averaging you can
make it interpolating so Peter mentions
that you can use the idea that you can
use some kind of singular kernel or
singular weighting scheme and so we can
do the same thing here so let's say you
want to make make British unit X you
could look at the K nearest neighbor and
then look at its corresponding labels
and if you just do had to did a vote or
an average you would not be interpreting
your training data but you can sort of
combine them in some weighted fashion so
that you are interpolating so this is a
particular weighting scheme that depends
inversely on the distance to the tester
the test point so if X is right on top
of one of the test points or sort of
training points the weight would be
infinity and so all your weight would be
your doing some normalization here so we
just predict the label of that
corresponding training point and you
know off away from many of the training
data it does some averaging so so this
indeed does give you some kind of
interpolation this was actually known as
I mentioned this is a scheme like this
where you don't just restrict to the K
nearest neighbor but you you look at
this thing all over all of your training
data this is something called the
Hilbert kernel estimate they were
studying the literature before
but I mentioned this is consistent but
didn't have any acent not asymptotic
rates whereas if you just localized to
just the K nearest neighbor you do get
optimal nonparametric rates it seemed
like the localization is the essential
in this case so the theorem that we can
prove about this scheme is a sort of a
kind of a theorem that you would expect
for nonparametric regression so again we
have some strong assumptions about on X
Prime on the distribution of X's there's
some regularity conditions they don't
want to get into and if we look at what
happens when the regression function is
smooth then the expected mean squared
error does something is something that
goes to 0 with n at the the right that's
minimax optimal ok so there's no sort of
at least in terms of minimax rates
there's not a cost to doing
interpolation this is something that was
pointed out by in the follow-up work by
Misha Sasha and Sasha for a different
nonparametric method that also uses some
localization because it's a it's a
singular kernel but is a compact kernel
it's sort of supported on the compact
set it's a localization seem to be
important in that case as well so we've
seen to scheme that where you use some
kind of localization for your prediction
and somehow in this case even if you are
interpolating they're heard of the
effect of the noise and I cannot doesn't
hurt does not hurt much the predictive
out of sample prediction accuracy of
your prediction rule ok so this was
about to scheme that ok so I guess
people do use nearest neighbor and some
I guess some people use these kinds of
nonparametric regression but ok so this
is what to be about neural nets so we
should talk about the other kind of and
n which is neural nets so what can we
say about neural nets so really not a
whole lot but we can done some
experiments to show that you know sort
of things do maybe are not as exactly
what you might expect so this is a case
where we are fitting just two layered
neural nets with one hidden layer in the
first case we
train the first layer in the second case
we are training the first layer and
these are just on em this problems
really simple data sets and this is the
test risk the training risks goings goes
to zero not always but pretty close to
zero but the test risk kind of shows
these two behaviors so when you have
very shallow orcs are a very narrow
Network another number of hitting use
that's very small then you are sort of
in the parametric regime you are
basically implementing something like
some parametric model and there seems to
be some trade-off in terms of bias and
variance but once you go beyond that
when you are actually interpreting your
training data this is at some point when
you have enough hitting units to so that
that becomes possible we are sort of in
a more interesting regime okay and
that's given by the second second design
here so this is something that we drew a
cartoon about and called a double
dissent but really the interesting part
is what's going on on this right part
beyond a point where you are perfectly
fitting the training data somehow I
think the x-axis of this of this plot is
a little bit artificial it's sort of why
do we care about a number of hidden
units is this maybe just something for
you know for computers is nice to have
fontana mall number of hidden units
maybe it's good for four people but
maybe nature does not does not really
care about how many hidden units you
really have it so it really matters to
something else which is the inductive
bias and people have looked at what
happens on the right-hand side of this
this curve in other contexts is
particular for a classification and the
story for classification has been that
okay what's happening when you have
bigger big higher and higher capacity is
that maybe you can achieve higher and
higher margins on your training data and
so the the hope is that we can have an
analogous story for regression and
that's starting to emerge ok so here's
one possible explanation for what's
going on in the the right hand side is
that when you are having when you
increase the number of hitting units
you're better approximating some
kind of a colonel and this would be
exactly the case if you are doing this
random Fourier features which is the
case in this experiment so here you do
not train the first layer of weights but
you only train the second layer then we
know as you increase the number of
hitting units this is getting closer and
closer to approximating a certain kernel
kernel machine and what happens at least
in the experiments is that we can see
you know the test Kris is going down as
we increase the number of hidden units
but so is the norm to our KHS norm of
your solution so it seemed like in this
case for this particular problem this is
a speech data set having small R cases
norm is the right inductive bias for the
problem and you're better able to align
yourself with this inductive bias by
having more and more hidden units so
that's really the only thing that can
help you here because in this case every
point to the right of this threshold
here the the training risk is zero so
there's nothing about the training data
to fit to the data that can help you
everything is determined by your
inductive bias so whether or not the
inductive bias is right with your method
that will ultimately depend determine
how good your prediction predict
predicted model is so we can't really
you don't have any theory about this but
I guess Andrea will tell us about some
some theory about what happens here we
can again show you something in the wing
year regression setting for why it is
the case that you know is it ever the
case that you have a smaller risk when
you have more features than then you try
to do some balancing of bias and
variance so we studied us in the context
of Gaussian linear regression this kind
of same setup as Peter but we have a you
know slightly slightly different set up
but our main question is not just about
what is the asymptotic risk or the
findeth non-ethnic risk of the right
endpoint here but we want to know is
there is there a particular point along
this x-axis that we should really be
thinking about is it ever the case that
we want to be to the left of the
interpolation threshold or to the right
so here we have to look at a particular
fix problem and an S how many feet
would be using in this silently near
regression model and we can show under
some kind of eigenvalue conditions this
is of course has to determine what how
well this this of course that Peter
showed that determines what happens at
the right endpoint but under is and some
other assumptions you can actually show
that there's nothing there's nothing to
the left of the interpolation threshold
that has a smaller risk than the right
endpoint there so this is a setting
where we can show that there are cases
where you know there's a benefit to
doing an interpolation as long as you
are sort of choosing an interpolator
that that sort of aligns well with the
right inductive bias so I think this I
want to sum up here I think you know by
now I think over the past year or so
becoming more and more clear that
interpolation overfitting it's not
really the same way that we should you
know we should not think about it the
same way that we think about overfitting
interpolation for parametric models we
release very small capacity models of
how the behavior is very different when
you are looking at over parameterize or
somehow very large predictive models and
of course in these cases you know
everything is about the inductive bias
look at the the data fitting is not
providing you any way to distinguish
between different interpolating models
so we identify two different properties
of what might be good interpolators the
first with the local prediction method
is smoothness from some kind of
averaging high dimensions seem to be one
property that can be beneficial and then
for things like neural nets or kernel
machines at least with linear models
some kind of low functions based norm
could be important as well so I think
the main open problems with
interpolation is to try to understand
what is the inductive bias for other
predictive models for a learning
algorithm that we use in practice and we
have some ideas about what you know
training neural nets with gradient
descent does but I think I don't think
this is fully answered yet
and really again like Peter I'm not
advocating that we find interpolating
fits this is just a phenomenon that we
want to understand but maybe there are
benefits to doing interpolation so we
have them stylized scenarios where we
can say that there are but maybe the
question is that whether it is actually
going to come down and practice thanks
[Applause]
after the training has gone to zero I'm
using batch gradient descent I shouldn't
be having any gradient at that point
okay so is it like you're using
stochastic gradient descent - yeah in
this particular experiment yeah we
didn't quite make it all the way to zero
here but but in like a simpler problem
where we're not where the optimization
is easy we can't make it actually zero
sure I have a question on the nasty rent
that you showed and there's a picture
next week do you do you prove that this
picture is what happens oh it's just
yeah okay so not the full curve but we
can that's we had before everything but
we can okay Swami I guess there's an
easy to prove but I guess you can show
three points like yeah I mean this this
one is kind of also trivial but the the
question is whether this this part here
is lower or higher than this point there
and that's that's something that's
interesting to ask and that's what we
can say something about
okay so next we have Sasha Rockland from
MIT who is gonna tell us about learning
methods that memorize data okay thanks
thanks for the invitation to this nice
workshop so I will continue the line of
talks with Peter and and Daniel and
luckily I can spend less time now on
introductions so let me just say that
this is based on work with the first
paper with Mischa Belkin and Sasha
birkoff I'll just briefly mention this
in light of Daniels talk and then there
are there is work with tangled young at
you Chi cago and my current student
should I so they're the the question we
would like to understand this kind of
learning method be successful fit
memorize the training data either to
talks now on this subject so this is the
outline of my talk
I will first very briefly describe
another I what's an estimator and Daniel
already already described a version of
that result and then I will talk about
Colonel Riddler's regression and I will
present three results first one is when
the dimension is constant it's not a
high dimensional problem the second
regime is when dimensionality is n to
some alpha when alpha is between 0 and 1
and the third result that I will present
is in the regime of dimension of the
data being on the order of number of
data points okay and then I will sketch
the application to white neural networks
in the final part ok so again you take
let's say M this data set you take two
digits treat it as a regression problem
and do Colonel Ridge regression with
some lambda and what you see in terms of
out-of-sample performance of this
estimator is that as you decrease lambda
all the way to 0
you get better and better out-of-sample
so it only helps to to fit the data
better and better and so the question is
why this is happening and we would like
to understand again we're not advocating
this necessarily as a solution but just
to understand what are the
generalization properties of such a
interpolating method and so we're
motivated by in particular by this paper
that Misha a and C on and and so much
so make a rote arguing that to
understand deep learning we need to
understand first understand kernel
learning and our path through this was
has been to start with these local
methods such as now there are lots an
estimator and type of methods that
Daniel just spoke about then talk about
more global kernel methods such as the
minimal norm interpolation of the data
and then say something about neural
networks okay so this has been our kind
of path through through these topics
okay so very briefly let me just spend
five minutes or less on this the nod
awry what's an estimator the data is
pairs why I equal to F star of X I plus
noise so this is the classical well
specified case and you know that f star
is smooth the classical mother I was an
estimator from the 60s at least is to
average the Y values according to some
measure of the distance between the
point of interest X and all of your data
points and average the Y values for
those data points and this weighting is
done according to a kernel function
which is appropriately scaled by H which
is the bandwidth of the of this kernel
okay so the types of kernel you can
consider are like a box kernel or one
minus x squared positive part or the
this Gaussian style kernel and so forth
so what's important is that you can put
a box of a kind of a constant area under
this
curve so that there is some averaging
that's happening locally and and all of
those will work with the results that I
will describe I discuss okay so for this
classical method what what controls fit
to data well it's clear that fit to date
is actually controlled by the height of
the kernel at zero okay and that you can
just read off from this from this
formula if if the height of the kernel
is very high at zero then you're
preferring a points which are very near
much more than the rest and so in this
averaging only the the the point where
you're querying at the data point that
you've seen survives and so in
particular if you define a kernel for
instance as 1 over the norm to the power
a and then min with some cap tau then
you see that as you increase tau to
infinity you get better and better
interpolating solutions okay and the
point is that this has nothing to do
with the actual bias-variance tradeoff
that's happening when you work with
these estimators so the the the fit to
data has nothing to do with with the the
the choice of the cap at zero okay and
so as Daniel mentioned this the kernel
of this sort has been analyzed by
Geoffroy at all in 98 and it was shown
to be consistent what is interesting is
that it's a wild kernel and and it
converges nowhere so if you fix a point
then you don't have convergence at this
point as n goes to infinity so so there
will be infinitely long sequence of
points where x where this just doesn't
behave well okay so what what the the
difficulty as Daniel mentioned what
happens here is that this kernel is too
global and you can't put a bandwidth
into this kernel because it will just
cancel in that
numerator and denominator denominator
calculation and so you cannot control
the bias and so what we did in our work
and this is similar to the work follow
up to Daniel work with Misha and Mitra
is that we cap the colonel at some
radios one and then show that you can
still choose a bandwidth for this
colonel in the minimax optimal way they
gives you a minimax optimal rate for any
dimension D assuming that the underlying
regression function is beta halter and F
hat n is interpolating if you set that
Tau to go to infinity so the takeaway
and this is a very quick summary of this
result this is not a surprising result
but it just says that fit today that has
nothing to do with with the
bias-variance tradeoff necessarily right
so you can come up with situations where
there is bias variance trade-off but
it's not reflected in the values on the
training data okay and in particular the
site of the kernel as parameterize by
tau height of the kernel at zero is
completely decoupled from the
bias-variance tradeoff which is given by
the bandwidth parameter age okay so
that's a very simple result that says
that there is a bit more to this story
and of course by the way when you see
this it becomes obvious that you can
take any estimator and and just append
the put little bumps on your favorite
estimator to fit the data
that that's obviously you will not see
any change in terms of the l2
out-of-sample performance but it will be
interpolating the data okay so the point
of this is just to see whether current
existing standard classical methods in
fact have this interplay of fit to data
and bias-variance tradeoff and and and
you can see that you can decouple these
all right so so there is more to this
picture as daniel already discussed and
spitter discussed in the sense that the
the point where the fit to training data
is low can occur anywhere on the under
on this regimes anywhere on the on this
plot and and it's not necessarily that
you have this shape of the bias-variance
you can have more complicated shapes but
but importantly the behavior on training
data doesn't really tell you where you
are I think that's a key thing to kind
of take take away or in you cannot
deduce from performance on training
sample where you are in this picture
okay so let me talk about something
that's more interesting which is Colonel
Ridge 'less regression or a minimal norm
interpolation I will use these two terms
interchangeably and let me define this
method first so we're probably familiar
with Colonel Ritter regression is just
square feet today that penalized by some
norm in the reproducing kernel Hilbert
space and the the usual conventional
wisdom is that you need to have a
nonzero regularizer if this hilbert
space is infinite dimensional or high
dimensional and there is a classical
line of work which tells you how to
choose that regularization parameter at
least in theory to obtain the correct
behavior but in practice as I already
mentioned in the beginning interpolated
solutions which is when you set lambda
to be equal to zero perform quite well
in practice and so we would like to
understand this phenomenon of course
when you set lambda to zero there are
infinitely many solutions and so what we
do is we pick the minimum norm solution
that interpolates the data so that you
can think of this as the limit of the
previous definition as lambda goes to
zero so a couple of remarks so first we
still are enforcing simplicity right so
if you think of the classical machine
learning Occam's razor we are choosing a
simple solution but the simplicity
is not reflected on you don't don't
suffer in terms of the fit to date right
so previously when you regularize you
pull away from the data points but here
we're saying just suppose that you go
through the data points and still choose
a simple solution right that's that's
the that's the bottom line
right so it is conceivable that such a
minimal norm interpolant generalizes
it's not out of the question we're still
not choosing completely crazy solutions
and also there is this line of work
connects to great in sentence the Casta
gradient descent that you converge to
the solution if you start from zero and
you do gradient descent and also there's
a line of work on neural tangent kernels
that show that neural networks if
they're sufficiently wide and they're
initialized appropriately randomly then
they converge to a rigidus regression
solution so I'm usually using Ridge
listed regression and minimal norm
interpolation interchangeably the same
thing okay so let's think about the
first the the the regime where dimension
is constant this is the input dimension
of the data X so X is in RG and and the
result that Peter Peter mentioned is for
this particular kernel although I don't
think this is a too special this is
chosen for convenience take a lap last
kernel are defined in this way that
that's a Euclidean norm on on the input
space X and Sigma is the the width of
this kernel brains and this is a how
wide that Laplace kernel is and and
let's do a minimal norm interpolation
with respect to this kernel so that the
theorem this is work with sheer joy is
that for odd dimension D for technical
reasons it's for odd dimensions but I
don't think there is anything special
with that probability no matter how you
choose the bandwidth of the kernel it
will not be consistent so risk is lower
bounded by a constant as long as D is
so if you think of D as being constant
with respect to n you do not have
consistency unless you make some further
strong assumptions okay so the the
result that I described before it on
another I Watson kernel that and the one
that Daniel described that works in any
dimension that's a local method this is
a global method it it takes the data
your data set and then instead of just
locally averaging and does something it
solves an inverse problem and and this
result shows that you really cannot get
consistency in low dimension it has to
be a high dimensional phenomenon if it
even exists okay so just a one word
about the proof imagine that you take
the bandwidth to be too large then the
right so the solution that you get this
minimal norm interpolant in at least in
one dimension you can think of this as a
as a rope hanging between nails right so
that's exactly the solution of a rope
hanging from nails and one dimension and
and so as you tighten Sigma you get
either a linear interpolant I should ask
physicist is that true as we tighten
Sigma you get a piecewise linear
interpolation which is related to what
Daniel talked about and that clearly is
not going to be consistent and if you
put Sigma to be too low then it will
just hang all the way to the ground
right so these are the two regimes so
this is the regime where you fit the
noisy value of the function but you're
not able to come back to this function
quickly enough so there is there's
there's you suffer in terms of the
prediction performance here around X I
and the other regime is is that it's
just hanging all the way to the ground
and then your your your off here and
what the result shows us that the the
these two regime
cover all the choices for for a signal
so you know you don't know you know
there is no way even after looking at
data there is no way you can choose
Sigma in a way that it will make it work
okay so that's the only a kind of well
not not that's not only but that's a
surprising kind of thing about this
result is that there is no way to
adaptively choose the bandwidth you were
just doomed okay so if kernel rigidness
regression if this minimal nor
interpolation works it has to be a high
dimensional phenomenon or you have more
assumptions on the on the data somehow
okay so now let me talk about this
result which should appear which should
be pushed archive maybe tonight there is
no high PR all right tonight or is there
there is a heck are okay tomorrow there
is no happy hour tomorrow okay so
tomorrow so this is a regime d2
proportional to end to the alpha alpha
between 0 and 1 and and so we're
thinking of and being large but also
dimensionality being large so and
dimension grows if you wish with n this
is the result that we get and I should
mention that this is an upper bound on
risk and we do not know if this
phenomenon is real or not and we should
ask some physicists sitting in the room
whether it is so what we get is the
following multiple descent shape at
least for the upper bound on the risk so
on the x-axis we have a parameter is a
ssin of the problem in terms of how d
scales with n so here D is n to the
Alpha alpha goes from 0 to 1 and this is
the rate for the risk for out-of-sample
performance of minimal norm
interpolation and it has this
interesting behavior that at integer
powers of 1 over alpha at integer powers
it it gets better and then for reasons
that you will see in a second this upper
bound
becomes vacuous at integer powers and
then dips again and again and again and
so you have this multiple instead of
double descent as Daniel I was
describing it as a multiple descent
behavior so we don't know if it's real
we try to get a lower bound and and
someone maybe here has more tools to to
prove a lower bound the function I will
state it in a second I will state the
assumptions here are the assumptions
okay so so what we look at is a kernel
of the form inner product so it's some
function of inner product a so H is the
function of the inner product we assume
that X is are iid in d dimensions and
for simplicity we assume that all the
coordinates are iid as well okay one can
try to relax that but because we're
discussing a high dimensional phenomenon
we need some independence in the
coordinates as Peter was mentioning we
assume that we have a Taylor expansion
that converges everywhere and that the
coefficients of this Taylor expansion
are positive okay so for that reason we
need to modify slightly this neural
network result to add the bias so that
we have all the all the coefficients
being positive that's in the later part
we assume that the regression function y
given x lives in the in the in the in
our KHS or this should be small K it
doesn't matter and it can be written in
this form with a bounded a Rho star okay
that's our assumption any questions
about this okay so here is the result
that we obtained in the scaling D is n
to the Alpha for alpha between 1 over
integer K 0 plus 1 and 1 over K in these
in fractional intervals
the out-of-sample performance or the
risk of this estimator the minimal norm
interpolant is d to the k0 over n plus n
over G to the K 0 plus 1 so this is
really just getting anything out of this
minimum normal operation and by the way
we're not using any assumptions about
the low rank news of data or anything
that this is a this is a full full rank
story right and and you see that here as
n goes between these two integer powers
you do get a rate of n to the minus beta
with that shape ok so let me give you in
the next 2 minutes some intuition the
minimal norm interpolant has this form
that's not difficult to see where the
curve the K X capital X is the vector of
kernel evaluations between X and X 1 up
to X X N and K X inverse is this inverse
of the kernel matrix of all the pairwise
kernel evaluations so that's the
empirical kernel matrix and now you can
write out the bias-variance
decomposition this is the variance term
and this is the bias term the second one
is the bias by square term and
essentially and I didn't write it down
but in one line you can see that the
variance term is is this right and and
this is where all the work is to show
that this this term can go to 0 and in
terms of the bias we didn't spend too
much time on the bias and just under
that assumption that we made here under
this assumption we show that the
variance is the dominant term so bias
squared is less than variance so we just
we just focus on on this and you can see
that there is quite a work to do here X
is a random variable from that
distribution and this is the empirical
kernel matrix so you you have to handle
you have to understand spectral
properties of these
random kernel matrices and let me give
you a roadmap of the proof just very
briefly so we look at the Taylor
expansion of the kernel and we truncate
the the Taylor expansion and we look at
the kernel with the truncation up to K
okay so this is a thing of this is
another kernel matrix but the the kernel
has been truncated and what we prove and
a lot of heavy lifting here has been
done by what was done by XI you shy the
student is that with hyper ability for
all the K below K 0 so remember K 0 is
that integer so that alpha falls between
1 over K 0 and 1 over K 0 plus 1 for all
the K up to that level this matrix K to
the K the truncated matrix has a plus K
over K non nonzero eigen values and all
of them are larger than Z to the minus K
you have comments yeah so okay cops it
is more common is that there was
mentioning to you during the break so
there we we put a lower bound that is
also no we're bound for can get
regression and and there you know the
technique looks very soon the setting is
largely differences on the sphere but I
think we have basically a similar lower
bound on the eigenvalues of the of the
kernel man in the same regime okay you
assume Gaussian and put her I we assume
input uniform on the sphere
okay okay so so so that this we don't
assume the a particular form of the
distribution on the coordinate so we
cannot go to hermit polynomials or some
known basis so what we do is we okay so
you write the the kernel matrix in this
form where each fee is indexed by the
data point I and some choice of the
powers on the polynomial so this p r1
through Rd is the you put power r1 on
the first coordinate are two on the
second coordinate and power are G on the
D coordinate and so this one is
difficult to analyze because of the
correlations and we have a grant we
would do branch meet or thing
orthogonalization on the on this basis
one z squared and so forth with respect
to L 2 P and pass to a different
representation and then show that this
ravishment process has a finite operator
of lambda is bounded okay so now it's
much easier to work with this basis and
what we show is a certain small bowl
property for for okay these functions
the small bowl property if
seen kind of analysis of least
eigenvalue then by Shahar Mendelsohn and
Vlad Merkel chin ski and others this
type of analysis shows up and and that
gives the lower bound on the on the
eigenvalue running out of time okay so
that's a the picture that we get we
don't know if it's real or not but
essentially as as you hit the integer
power you gaining one more dimension in
that expansion the tiled Taylor
expansion and it takes data to to kind
of get better in the now with that the
extra dimension and so that's why you
see the these strange form at least in
in the in the upper bound and maybe
someone can prove a lower bound you
don't know any other for which for which
it's tight just yeah like the rate is
not it's not going to zero yeah so I'm
all for equals to zero and we know that
you might not be done and I have one
minute left so I can discuss this point
okay okay so maybe I should skip this
so in this regime D equals to an or
proportional to n at this point this at
least doesn't give you anything but this
result doesn't assume anything about the
data and so in the work with tang Yong
Yong what we did previously is to
analyze this point and show that if you
do have something about the data such as
a spectral decay of the the data then
you can still get something that that is
small okay so you could get good
performance in this regime under the
additional assumptions like in in in
Peters talk that that the rank or some
effective rank of the data is is small
okay okay so that's that's that let me
not do the details
of this and just briefly say okay I
think people know this you you take a
wide neural network that's randomly
initialized with W each coordinate of W
being drawn from let's say normal so
again we have to do this we have to
append this coordinate so that all the
coefficients are positive in the Taylor
expansion and then you do you calculate
the gradient of the square loss and then
you see that the gradient flow gives you
a convergence of this function on an any
point so for all points this converges
to a rigidus solution with respect to
this kernel okay and the kernel has this
ugly form I think everyone knows this
and as M goes to infinity as the number
of neurons in this one layer neural
network converges to infinity
the the kernel sorry this should be
little H M converges to this kernel our
cosine kernel if you wish with with this
function and then we show that the
theorem that I just stated before with
integer powers with that multiple
descent that actually can be extended to
this case where here we have a slightly
more complicated function than just a
function of a product so okay so you
know the I think we've made very little
progress here but there is something
there are some interesting questions
kind of in the middle that we played
around with and I think there is a lot
of work to be done
in that regime thank you
[Applause]
any question comments right so I think I
just missed part of the talk I think so
when where you had this exact thing with
a lot of dissent is a problem the
problem setting what is the ground food
within the problem saying what is the
problem setting the problem setting is
yes so the assumptions are like that the
kernel is of that form such a functional
product and coordinates are independent
they don't have to be iid but just for
simplicity independent and and
identically distributed
it's a Gaussian we have a Taylor
expansion and the regression function is
representable as a combination of
kernels yeah so I mean it's a it's a
yeah it's a high dimensional thing so
you can do your concentration right so
you you might be like yeah so in this
setting it's not easier to go I think I
think if you force it to be on the
sphere then you have to take the the
Hermit polynomials and and yeah but but
in this setting we don't assume anything
about the P except for sub gosh I Nancy
I'm not sure it's easier to force it to
be on the sphere oh I don't mean force
it I mean I just mean like a high
dimensions like the sphere like this is
this call the trace of Aramis here
another truck yeah okay
okay so for the last talk of the morning
we're gonna have andre i montaner from
sand rod with no tears about the
generalization error of random features
okay thanks for the invitation
very nice workshop so as several of the
previous speakers I need I can I can you
know leverage economy of scale and do no
introduction but but you know do a
couple of slides about my quarters this
is based on three papers with six
quarters the last paper I'll talk about
is with song is precise as in tortex
blah blah blah song is there so go talk
to him and ask him difficult questions
the second one is with song Bruce and
Theodore and actually is related to
something that you know the paper that
Sascha mentioned and the first word
paper that I talked about this with some
older people that don't deserve don't
need introduction all right so so the
motivation for us was again this paper
and the sequence of paper and particle
here I reference this by Misha than
issue and Smith Mandel about the two
layers phenomenon but you know
everything about this already and the
question is do we understand these
curves and and what does it mean we do
we understand these curves for us there
are a series of interesting phenomena
going on here in this curve and let me
tell you what are the four most
important thing that I see there is this
peak at the interpellation threshold so
the fact that you know when you start
interpolating the beta the risk shoots
up this is a little bit of a mystery
there is something that you know people
mentioned before and this striking that
the minimum is in the over parametrized
regime is in the interpolation regime so
you need to interpolate in this model to
get optimal risk so you have to really
put a lot of parameters in your data on
top of that many of this curve
perhaps this one but surely others are
monotone decreasing in the electrometer
eyes regime so not only you need to over
parameterize but you need to our parent
eyes really a lot right so you know if
you put whatever number of parameters is
better to add parameters to your model
and and finally you are using no no
regularization or at least no explicit
regularization there is probably some
regularization that is induced by the
algorithm like the mini normal
regularization if it is least mr. square
fitting but but you don't put a positive
number down don't put any positive
explicit regularizer okay so ideally
would like a model that you know has all
of these features and ideally would like
this model to do real neural networks so
here is what I would like to do if I was
good enough I would take neural network
say two layers neural networks within
neurons so here I fit parameters AI and
WI I would train stochastic gradient
descent until the gradient error gets to
zero compute the test error for this
network that I produce and then be able
to compute D's in analytic form and
display this phenomena okay this is my
dream calculation I am NOT able to do
this perhaps we'll be able to do it in a
few years but at the moment is is too
far so what what we can do so far is
work with you know towards that goal is
work work with linearizations of this
neural network and this is also a line
of work that has been mentioned before
and the idea is instead of working with
two layers neural network I work with
some linear approximation the simplest
linear approximation of eight layers
neural network is the random feature
model so this was was mentioned by
daniele is simply the model in which I
don't fit the the first layer weights
and don't fit the WI the WI are are
given at random and just fit to the AI
okay and throughout the talk the WI so I
will live in D dimension my data will be
in this dimension and my model will be
the state
the wi uniform on the sphere there is of
course another linearization that is
even more interesting but more difficult
to work with is the realization that you
obtain when you Taylor expand around
around W random w so this is this neural
tangent kernel and I actually brought
only a piece of it here that is that you
know the most challenging piece is when
you expand the W I so here fix the W and
I fit this parameter AI but the AI
multiplied the Ickes okay so this
produces some technical complication
that makes the model more difficult okay
and and you know there is a sequence of
papers that show that in certain regime
this is not a bad approximation so this
is the plan of the talk for today I
first discussed a very simple Gaussian
model for this linearization and what
what it can explain then I'll discuss
the real you know basically the the two
linearizations that I mentioned and the
approximation question for this
linearization and finally I'll discuss
the the generalization of question so
the finite dataset question okay so here
is the Gaussian model and this is going
faster rate because it's very similar to
you know very much related to things
that have been mentioned before so again
the same thing is that I have n data
points and say that I construct features
di for instance the two linearizations
that are discussed before give me
specific way to construct these features
and then my data are linear functions of
this feature plus an arrow okay and and
I do fitting by doing Ridge regression
and then taking lambda to 0 that gives
me the mean normal solution and what
I'll be studying is the test error you
know that that boils down to to this so
the error that you make on any you new
data set so you predict with the beta
hat times that and you compare it with
to labor's that is beta zero times
that does this setting make sense okay
and and what I mean by stylized modeling
means that I take you know my features
did they die to be IAD Gaussian with
some covariance well and this of course
is not very realistic because this field
is nonlinear so even if your data were
dashing to start with they are not not
being non Gaussian but you know it's a
it's a starting point okay and and you
know if you set in few if you set
yourself in this model and you like P
and then go to infinity so P will be the
number of parameters and then the number
of of data points we let P and then go
into infinity and with the ratio
converging to some fixed number gamma
you can use random matrix theory to
compute the limiting risk and the
simplest case that is really an exercise
is the case in which you know Sigma is
the identity the covariance is an
identity in this case you obtain a very
simple formula very simple explicit
formula that is the following one for
gamma less than one you know you get you
know a curve that diverges as gamma goes
to one this only depends on toe so here
toe is the variance of my noise so this
goes to 0 with toe so this is pure
variance and then Fergana bigger than 1
you get two pieces one piece that is
variance and this decreases with gamma
this piece proportion to toe is what you
know mostly peter was focusing on and
then you get in this model by a bias
term that increases with gamma okay so
the the paper contains result not only
for unit covariance but for you know
general covariance meaning than the
empirical distribution of the of the
eigenvalues converges weakly so this is
the standard setting or random matrix
theory and not only for the ocean but
for linear transform of a vector with
iid entries so more general in deciding
the formulas are not that explicit and
they are not moving that explicit
because they depend on the
distribution of the eigenvalues this but
there is a general technology to the get
this formula and this is of course
related to these two papers that were
presented before so if you plot this
curve already something interesting
happens so this is the curve that you
obtain I plot versus number of
parameters of a number of data point I
plot the risk and this is the
interpolation threshold and this is the
peak aligned threshold okay and this is
tree value of the SNR what is the SNR
this snr is the ratio of the norm of
beatitude to the size of the noise so
the SNR is R square over tau square so
as the SNR gets large you get
interestingly so interestingly you get
this peak so you get of the four
features for you know properties that I
described before you get two of them you
get the peak at the interpolation
threshold okay we get this is 4 min norm
so we are banishing explicit
regularization we get a monotone
decreasing curve in the other
parameterize regime so we get also this
in these cases but we don't get the
global minimum when the temperature
range in the other parameters in regime
okay so the global minimum is the under
parameterize regime there is another
more fundamental thing that is not
satisfying about this model is that this
model the way I set it up it ties
completely the dimension with the number
of parameters so you know the feature
vector X I live in D dimension or P
dimension and I use exactly P number of
parameters so the two are tied together
which is not appealing one way to go
beyond that is to study a mixed pacified
model I will not describe it mush before
here but basically why I you have in
reality says they died and the till die
features that are jointly Gaussian but
you know fit only using the Jedi
okay so use only that they die not dead
till die and so the model is mess
misspecified and now if you if you play
with this model you can get global
minima in the other parametrized regime
so is the model is permissive fide what
happens is that the curve you get the
peak here
monotone decreasing here or monotone
decreasing and then increasing but you
can get a global minimum here for
instance this is the green curve okay so
this is so far as far as you can get
with this you know simple Gaussian model
you can probably play with your Sigma
and your misspecification ratio and get
a sort of all sorts of geology of this
curve and move the the global minimum
much to the right even infinitely long
far on the right but you know as you see
the model is a little bit too flexible
in a way it contains a lot of freedom
you can specify the degree of miss
specification and whole covariance okay
so the next thing I want to do is go
towards the more you'll see a realistic
model or a more concrete model and the
setting will be the one on nonparametric
regression so assume that I buy ID data
and the data is uniform the feature
vectors are uniform on the sphere for
technical reason the sphere has radius
square root of D but that's not
important
and then the labels are just some based
functions and grant through function f
star of X I plus noise and the noise is
Gaussian with mean zero at various toy
so this is exactly the model that Sasha
was mentioned being accepted the data
are uniform on the sphere or you can
think of them as iid Gaussian
okay so we have this random future model
that I described before is the model in
which I fit only the second layer
weights and the way I fit the second
layer weights I'll do Ridge regression
again
so I minimize over day I know the
empirical risk plus a rich panel team so
one way to think about it is of course
that this is approximating a kernel is a
low-rank approximation of a kernel
method okay and and I'm interested in
the test error that is what I described
before and my first question is okay
what what can a fit if in the population
limit when I have infinitely many data
here I will have three parameters right
I have n that is the number of data
points so this is the data size capital
n that is the number of neurons and D
that is the dimension okay so the first
question is what happens if the data is
you know infinite in the population
limit this is a little simulation in
which you know I take this random
feature model and I take a function that
I'll describe in a minute and I fit
random future models with increasing
number of neurons 4820 hundred sixty in
20 dimension plot the test error and
they compared test error with a row
naught R naught is the test error of the
trivial predictor the predictor that
predicts every word zero okay so as you
see this curve if you follow one data
set for instance I don't know the right
it spikes in goose-down this is the
double descent curve here we are
interested that small n go to infinity
so I'm interesting here seeing what is
the asymptote when you have a lot of
data and you see that the asymptote is
not too good right with 40 neurons
I do know better than three
predictor we done you know with with the
hundred sixty I do a little bit better
and if the dimension increases things
grew worse and worse if the dimension is
100 even with eight hundred neurons I
cannot do better than the trivial
predictor so this was my first encounter
with these random film models and I was
like this is not really where this
clever method right now if I might ask
of course okay so so the conclusion
random feature is no better than trivial
predictor you might ask is this because
your target function is very difficult
and this is the target function that I
was trying to uh okay it's not very
difficult in my war but you know it's a
second-order polynomial or craps is very
very difficult for other people now ii
not reprehend so so a random feature mod
that seems to be unable to fit
second-order polynomial on high
dimensional spheres okay interesting
okay can we prove this yes we can prove
that so the theorem goes like this take
an integer Ella and assume that the
number of of neurons is less than D to
the L plus 1 okay so if the dimension is
a hundred probably you cannot dream of L
bigger than another three five three
four or something like that right so fix
it integral and and okay there is an
extra Delta positive then with that
probability what happens is that the
risk of random features it is they
composes roughly in two parts one it is
the risk of random feature on the
low-degree component of F star so you
can write F star as the composite in to
you know the projection on low degree
polynomial and the projection the
orthogonal complement and the projection
is with respect to the uniform measure
on the sphere right in these two of the
uniform measure on the sphere and Here I
am saying is that the low degree
component
brand-new feature does something but on
the high degree component
it doesn't do anything right so this in
particular is a lower bar so for example
Anya to come back to my previous model
so this is in other words this is the
risk that I would obtain by fitting
degree L polynomials by doing least
square feet and the population will
attack the real polynomial so this is
saying for instance is that if the
number of neurons is less than this
square then random future Praeger
regression doesn't do better than linear
regression and this is what was
happening in my example before if you
think of my example before this is zero
projection on linear functions so here
you know a linear predictor does very
bad and the random feature is doing very
bad okay
of course there are all sorts of you
know results about random feature
regression in particular there is a very
nice paper by Francis but doing this but
you know strange enough it was never
studied in this kind of an MD growing
together asymptotics and okay here I
mentioned the results for random feature
we can prove the same result for a
neural tangent kernel the only thing
that you can changes is that no it's not
number of neurons that come matters but
the number of parameters which is number
of neurons x dimension in the neural
tangent and the the number of parameters
is n times T so now neural tangent
doesn't look any better than random
feature from the approximation question
so the picture that you get from this is
the following so you know what we give
get is really a lower bound but we can
actually prove also an upper bound for a
new feature is that as n increases so I
plot your log on Yavin this is a cartoon
that I did just like log n over log T is
the exponent so log n over log equal 1
means that n is proportional to D and
proportion to the square and proportion
to the tube etcetera at each of this
thresholds the risk goes down and these
levels are basically the residual or
from the error of projecting one low
degree polynomial is the high degree
component of this by a simple mapping we
can obtain or just a comment we can
obtain a similar result for kernel
regression but we're now capital n is
replaced by the number of points so I
think this staircase picture is
basically very much related to the you
know the exact picture in social stock
yeah but but that okay I can explain the
mapping but you can switch capital so we
have here is so this is a an finite and
infinity and and finite okay you're
you're setting is an infinity because
it's the kernel
but and finite huh turns out that these
two plays exactly the same
so Sigma place the role of K and you can
switch the tool at least in this model
so so we have a you know as a corollary
of this in the paper we give very
similar result where this is log
lowercase n and is a lower bound okay so
this leaves open of course the question
of what happens at finite time and so we
like to now understand the full
generalization curve the model is the
same as than the last heart but now I
take the tree and and I did going to
infinity and proportional and the two
ratio will be say one and say two and
this choice is just to confuse you so
say one is basically number of neurons
of a number of dimension M say two is
number of data points and as I stick to
this this this ground truth function we
have some result about more general
function but basically this is the
difficult part if you think of the
previous in this regime you cannot fit
quadrille
dick function or higher their function
so you can only hope to fit the higher
order terms behavior is noise okay this
is the theorem I didn't write the
authors but this is again with song okay
you define a couple of parameters that
depends on the activation function and
then the theorem looks like this that
for any lambda equal to zero the risk of
random feature is equal to something
plus mod of term and this something
depend on theta this parameter that
depends on Sigma I want say to the
regularization and you know decomposes
into a bias term that is proportional to
the norm of beta 0 and the variance term
and depends on two functional
calligraphic being calligraphic B and
when I use calligraphic typically for me
means that this is quite complicated but
but these are explicitly given there are
explicitly do I mean so okay it's a bit
with a given font it fits in a slide
with a suitable for integer but but okay
if you look at it this is really solving
tool area degree for equation to find in
this and substituting this formula into
pulling in three polynomials and then
you get this so it's something that you
have the most difficult thing you have
to do is solve the first degree equation
that in 2019 we can do okay so if you
don't like to parse that formula this is
what we are really doing that the math
that is behind this is random matrix to
learn for kernel inner product random
matrices and is something for which you
know technology exists and if you know
about random matrix Theory you recognize
that these are typical formulas that
appearing and the matrix theory these
are still G's transform
and this is fixed-point equation for
still cheese transforms
okay so you can plot them their degree
fourth equation you can solve them you
can plot them and here and what it looks
this is for lambda zero plus so this is
the ridge less limit and now you have
divergence at the interpolation
threshold global minimum in the over
parametrized regime and monotone
decreasing in the other parameterize
regime and actually you know the global
minimum so it's in the extreme of a
parameterization so this is the the
curve that appears that is empirical in
the paper of Daniel and so they trotted
your simulations point like this now we
can compute a curve okay what insights
can we get from this formula
okay so I'll mention three insights you
know three or four insights we always
get the singularity of the interpolation
threshold and the minimum is in the
extreme of a parameterized regime so
this is plotted versus number of
parameters or number of neurons over
dimension so we always get this curve
goes up and then goes down and then goes
up and it goes down both variance and
and and bias are singular so this is
different from the simple linear
regression model that we and they
analyzed in that model this divergence
here is a purely variance phenomenon so
there is this variance bias
decomposition that the emergency is just
variance here we plot the bias and
variance and both diverge so in
particular the curve is basically the
same shape even at zero noise the same
phenomenon appears at lambda positive so
here what I do is that we do is that I
plot as a function for various values of
lambda and here is as a function of
you know the interpolation ratio the the
over parametrization ratio capital n of
a lowercase n so you see the the lambda
equals zero the regionalist case is the
dashed curve and this is from the yellow
to the dark blue these are decreasing
value of lambda so when lambda is very
large you don't see peak but then the
peak starts developing but nevertheless
at any fixed lambda you get that it's
better to go to extreme over
traumatization and this is this is an
interesting phenomenon is that you see
so here I plot two curves for you know
one curve for low SNR and the curve for
high SNR and then I plot it now as a
function of lambda for various value of
the ratio psi 1 over X I 2 which is
capital n over N ok so it always you see
first of all as the ratios I wanna
website two changes the various curve as
a lower envelope and the lower envelope
is where you want to see it where you
want to work this lower antelope will
not happen to be at Solano web site to
infinity so in the extreme erode over
parameterization regime but now the
behavior is qualitatively different at
high SNR at the lowest signal as a plot
as a function of lambda at low snr the
minimum is achieved at some positive
lambda it means that at low snr what you
should do is over parameterize a lot but
then put a little bit of regularization
okay so you shouldn't interpolate you
should over parameterize because this
makes some how your model reach but then
you should regularize but in the word so
this is kind of the traditional a more
traditional philosophy this is something
that is more surprising or it's more you
know phenomenon that you see in neural
networks I would argue is that yeah you
should over permit tries to make your
the richer but then you should not
regularize so the minimum is achieved at
and there exists a critical value of a
DSLR such that above that critical value
this is what happens and this is
something that I like because ok you can
imagine that data set in which you know
new modern neural networks or large
model works well our highest in our data
sets and so you see this happening ok
as a conclusion okay I think you know so
far I understand
two mechanism so there is this phenomena
our perimeter ization that avoids poor
generalization as to to met mechanisms
for this happening one is is this early
stopping regime that that you know I
spend some time working on and another
one is this high dimensional calculation
regime that I didn't really I don't
really understand but I think we are
understanding more and more and there
are a bunch of question of course what
happens with fully trained networks and
really I think from a practical
perspective most interesting question is
this one
when is extreme over parameterization
and interpolation optimal so when when
is that you can go to a to a your
practitioner tells amia what you are
doing is right or no you should
regularize your network and you know as
far as I can tell this is one case this
random future case is one case in which
I can compute a value of the snr
intelligent you know above this snr you
should go that way below you should
regularize
[Applause]
your password for what activation of the
non-linearity the activation in the plus
the activation is a renew but if you
look at the foyer if you carefully look
at the formula now if you look at the
theorem this depends on Sigma only
through these two parameters B 1 and B
star and what are B 1 and B star B 1 I
didn't write it here so okay so B 1 is
the projection of Sigma onto linear
function in the space in the gosh of
space and B star is the projection onto
nonlinear function so second order and
more function in l2 of Gaussian the fact
that in it's everything in l2 of
Gaussian is because we are taking data
on the sphere if you took they tie a d
like Sasha is doing probably with well
this is linear model so it's 1 yeah so
you have to go to nonlinear models do to
get it different you can do that so the
behavior the price behavior is too large
factor here I subtract the culture or
something where the eigenvalues not
degenerate or like you have like large
against this thing yeah is the related
to the fact that there is symmetry right
right
so this fact is is really related to you
know you you hit there is the generous
in the against basis of a given degree
and then you eat the space and you start
fitting but still I mean you know be
forming it's kind of surprising it
because you know here for instance you
still have a number of parameter that is
d to the 1.9 now a clear it's not clear
that you wouldn't have decreased a
little bit there
right so it's clear that yeah but let me
add something so but this is not limited
on a sphere because if you do for
instance iid data you will have
invariance and a permutation and then
you have the same degeneres but like if
you look at like the eigenvalue
situation of like CR III doesn't look
like a step it's just like a natural
cane distribution so do you feel like
there's like what is the settings okay I
mean I mean what I like about this is
that this model uniform on the sphere or
other similar minds that it decouples a
little bit the question of learning the
distribution of X from learning the
function f right and I think that the
most difficult part of this whole
business is learning the function f
rather now or you know figuring out low
dimensional structures in function f now
we have something that you know we
worked a bit on is the following what
happens if you try to extend to this
result to elliptical basically to
something that doesn't lie on a sphere
but lies on ll9 lip side and something
that comes out is that you have a
similar you have similar D but the
similar phenomenon but now there is an
effective dimension that depends on is
not the ambient dimension of course and
is not reduced and it depends on the
thing so we are okay
I cannot go in more detail now but you
know some kind of elliptical data
[Applause]
you